hey I was going bros my name is fear to
pass III went back to check out my
girlfriend and I'm like what is this
where the [ __ ] is this guy it says hi
there I'm the new guy try me not her
obviously we're we're not gonna cheat on
Evie um
you ever wondered why we are here oh
don't smile at me disgusting who the
[ __ ] are you yes that is the appropriate
response I agree
are you dating evey Oh anybody no good
do you like evey I don't know what it is
good now let's keep it that way shall we
I don't know you but you were okay I
guess
oh my god he's more [ __ ] than evey
this is great okay well let me introduce
myself my name is PewDiePie well I don't
know yes oh my god [ __ ] we have so much
work to do
are you my awkward adopted child I will
have my own children when I get married
okay well please don't eat them I'm
seriously worried about you why not
you're making me a little gum no don't
none is this Pacific tell me a joke
you will social bar you [ __ ] ass dick
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you hope you [ __ ] die
you look stupid
Thanks so do you [ __ ] you are you a
directioner McCool's oh you can't say I
am all right Alice slaps your booty he
likes it Jesus Christ
shakes Beauty halter Oh what the [ __ ]
let's head inside
keep smiling put sound on your head
oh well this is getting juicy boots on
your new booty
Karrueche [ __ ] I like it
tell me a story a story my god I [ __ ]
hate him so [ __ ] much you've told me
a story okay you're adopted
I don't think he liked it hahaha you too
um thank you you don't know that uh are
you wearing any pants
no all right all right all right all
right
what's your name actually should
probably ask that first boom boom boom
yes my name is Pam um are you you mean
Adi
yes are you a bro
yes I'm agree loominatee is on our side
brows yeah did you just slapped my mouth
with your feet how did you know oh my
God he's so stupid
put your feet on my face I just did done
it's kind of a weird thing to say to
someone you just met but I'll go with
him there you go bro there ya go it's
gonna be good hey can you like it bad oh
yeah he likes ships like that office I
am chasing you mom what turns you on
oh that window drinks blood from your
name you can't do that I'm gonna have to
stop this is freaking me the [ __ ] out
turns into you of every junk you into
some light oh you dick [ __ ] you stupid
[ __ ] I hate you go away
alright fries this stupid idiot I hate
him
he's such such a douche maybe like if we
die this episode let me know if you want
to do more when I talk to point bot and
I will see subscribe to come ready don't
Sparkle oh my [ __ ] office
you ha ha ha oh my god she's up there
little old lady